oh guys don't worry we're on an airplane
right now and your child who's asleep
next to me don't worry about it
ah good how is our child
oh i don't have a child oh yeah no i'm
alone oh weird oh cool
dude no obligations no obligation where
are you can you guys see me are you in
front of me
i think i'm off to your right behind you
when
i don't see anybody like i see do you
have a styrofoam coffee cup sitting in
front of you on your tray
no i do not [ __ ] is that a mountain to
our left all the wing is gone is that
bad
yeah there is something on the wing wait
no there's not a wing
something on the wing
uh something there dude
prizes are loud [ __ ] dude
all right well that was fun oh i don't
like that
do you see a man standing over my son
right now yeah yeah he's stealing your
baby
his face looks grippy he's hiding he's
not good he's hiding
he shouldn't smile like that if he wants
to make a good first impression he needs
to hide those chompers yeah
if you're gonna steal our child do it
without a smile on your face low energy
eat something or get some rest
hungry find something to eat wade and i
were sitting in each other
that's interesting oh yeah we were hey
don't hold your hands up in front of me
like that yeah hey guys
you guys want to see how high my mouth
sensitivity is
hey there's food over here guys look
around the plane for some food
oh i mean no no everyone has separate
items so i ate that food you ate that
food
oh okay in that case i'm not sharing any
of this [ __ ] mine mine mind my mind
all right good well i mean you are in
the way though well i was trying to
see what was on the toilet oh you the oh
that's bob okay sorry
oh yeah that wasn't me now you are on
the way well i
yeah i'm hungry i am you just uh slowly
gonna work my oh that more food hang on
uh
oh there's a little little axe right did
you know there's an axe yeah right here
yeah oh man it's right here on this lady
thanks man thank you right there
thank you did you guys get all the uh
goodies off the floor back here and
stuff yeah yeah
i think so yeah did you check all the
seats because there's stuff in the seats
yeah a couple of them i can't get back
in anyway now so it's all you bob
i'm damn how do you start how do you
attack dab there we go down
oh i see my guy was just swinging wildly
left to right
mark did i just hurt you no i just got
oh did the bird just land on the board
landed on me
get down is there team damage can we
hurt each
oh my god i just saw feathers flying
away you want to try to hit me bob see
if it hurts me
okay this seems like a bad idea oh i
don't think it did wait dude again you
just think you're just a reaction oh
yeah
i don't watched it oh wait yeah i do
lose health yeah i probably noticed that
i uh i didn't lose healthy
approve it no well keep opening the
containers because
plenty of goodies this one's locked yeah
hit it with your there you go
spatula whatever whatever you hit it
with your wang jangler yeah the wang
jungler that's exactly what it is
yeah do you think gordon ramsay's
watching right now of course he's my
biggest fan
what else has he got going on bob's
biggest fan actually he's just a chef
[Laughter]
yeah we need to find a place to live
wang sure pretty sure oh no guys my
inventory is full
yeah oh no yeah that's why we need to
find a place to set up camp
step one build a shelter how build a
shelter
log stick you click well we don't have
to build it here as a thing
no yeah do we now i mean there's a bunch
of resources here i don't know
always built on the beach and i don't
remember if there was a good reason for
that or not i don't think there is
i actually wonder if it is good idea to
stay near that well we need
fresh water and lots of trees so the
only thing i can remember that's close
to the beach that's useful is you can
kill the turtles and you can use turtle
shells to make
rain catchers right right how do i open
my
inventory oh there we go how do you feel
you click on the thing in your survival
book and then you place it on the ground
and then you grab items in the
environment and you
press b for b
ah yes
yeah thank you
melon bar melon bar melon bar are we
building here down by the beach because
i've got a
fire pit ready to place let's do the
beach go down by the beach yeah
is that in a specific direction is this
map the same thing i don't
remember it at all i think i think we're
an island yeah i think any direction oh
this is totally the beach
follow the coast until we get to a nice
place so you guys like it is farther
away from the trees oh
we tall do we want to maybe build here
is there a size restriction what if we
built on this plateau
and then we could have our water
collection down there
i know there's a good beach that's like
a nice slope and there's trees like
inches from it's not like that big drop
off i think we keep looking maybe
okay okay okay look bob you're gonna see
it's gonna be a great beach
okay okay it's just it's been a minute
okay i'm a little rough
okay okay okay in fact i have no idea
which direction it is
good all right look i found a house
right here pre-built oh god
dude they already have sleeping nooses
you just slip that bad boy around your
neck and then just handle dangle
yourselves
you are right about that i want to take
that sleeping noose with me i'll get
your nooses too
calm down with the ax swinging my dude i
was trying to oh
i found a new clothing outfit oh i found
a new clothing outfit oh
now we're different the same i wrote a
new glory
oh that's cool mark good job buddy what
a nice timmy photo we have
yeah you guys got pictures of my kid too
that's yeah do kind of concerning
i don't know how i feel about that i
don't know about this partnership is
this your beach
no this is another the beach i'm talking
about has like a boat that you can go
out to
that's one specific sport that's like a
one angle remembering i just remember
that yeah but we don't need that
specific one that's the banger beach
well you guys pick wherever you want
then i don't know i just that's what i
remember
is weight leading or not i thought we
were following wade i don't listen you
shouldn't
you literally remember you leave wade's
in charge we're doing what your weight
says
wait what that's a horrible idea this is
kind of an awful
beach but this is a beach beach but it's
by a river there's a river over there
that's probably fresh water
yeah rivers are good that's something
different and uh we could start building
before we get attacked and
are horribly murdered that's always a
good option can i just get
oh we're clean i'm no longer bloody
water is good oh that's right oh yeah
well now the water's bloody but
i'm sure this doesn't have any parasites
or anything in it so it's probably fine
i think i already got one of those penis
worms
it's flatter right there we need to cut
down all those trees
can we what is happening we need to
build a base i know but
pick a spot holy [ __ ] let's pick a spot
we'll build it we'll make it work
every spot we get you're like oh this is
a good spot oh right there it's a little
flatter
[ __ ] here i don't know so okay good
excellent here on the slope
you sure about that yep no why wouldn't
you pick a flat spot
all right right here's flat right up
here it's very flat bird
i'll kill him i haven't got a friend oh
he's my friend
is everyone else that was me
i think you can make armor out of him if
you want to play him and reply
how do i how do i unequip the building
that's in my hand right now because i
have a building
oh thank god i was following the iguano
around helplessly
all right i'm placing the shelter my
dudes all right my dudes
not many trees around here let me be
fine all right we'll be fine
three feet that way well there's like
three trees
you know how many trees we need uh more
than three
yep all right we each need our own
shelter oh my god do we need
seven logs is that how many locks we
need for a shelter yeah of course
that's for the shitty one you should
build a log cabin
does a log cabin require a lot of logs
is that what you're saying yes it does
did you you did hunting shelter i'm
guessing it's yeah it's the part you're
following the steps in the book right
step one haunting shelter if you hit b
oh hey look
go to the first page of the book did you
guys know there's a hunting shelter oh
my god i'm the strongest man alive
you can use rocks and crap how many logs
can i carry
oh i can carry two logs okay i kept
picking them up as i was walking forward
so i thought i was just picking them all
up oh six logs more
more these trees are gonna get farther
and farther away i'm just
saying that out loud singing out loud
but you know
how it is calm down just climb up the
side of this hill and throw
you know we could chop down the trees
above us and throw the logs down all
right we
could could i like fall and break my
legs is that bad
yeah try it oh you can crouch jump oh
hell yeah dudes
guess who's on the high ground now
anakin
uh who's that i'm pretty sure he's a
star trek character
all right my hunting shelter's done
great yeah mine's done i'm doing stuff
all right cool man you want me to help
finish yours uh mark i've already got
some extra logs cut over if you want to
pick up the ones that already pre-cut
yeah
i got some too but you know teamwork
makes stream work bob we're getting your
shelter up all and ready to go
oh don't worry it's raining logs boys oh
my god this is what i like to hear
we can build a log holder as well
there's a ton of like little uh
maintenance things that we can do to
make life easier yeah just keep chopping
those trees down he'll come down
yeah just throw them right on top all
right we gotta start building the
campfire
uh one more log beside you i'll i'll get
the campfire you finished that
campfire all right three done shelters
okay well later we'll start gathering
more rocks
yeah and we have fire oh i think this
tree is gonna fall off the cliff
oh god hell yeah dude it's common my
dudes no it's not
oh there it is fire pit yeah we should
have probably built the fire pit i guess
no no you're doing everything great i
mean it's just a basic fire just to get
some light it was going to be dark you
know
ooh log sled would be a good idea well
more logs coming in
slot style let me worry about it let me
get the log holder going because i feel
like
there you go my dudes can we not get
water from the river do we have to use
the
shell oh no we should be able to like a
lake or something too it's
dark i can't see we could sleep we
couldn't sleep
i can't see i've got my own fire up here
so i'm going to continue the logs
the log mission okay i'm gonna try to
run down to the river and see if i can
just drink out of it
you can't i tried that right parasites
penis worms
well why why would that be any better
than any other place
i guess i'll drink one of these uh sodas
we picked up on the
oh yeah we got sodas you're right we got
sodas glug
yeah right somehow i'm not i'm i'm fully
drank what did i drink something um
i don't know did you eat berries or
something that give maybe i didn't eat
anything
i did not eat anything since we were on
the plane and yet i'm full on
thirstiness
bob your kid timmy here yeah he's got a
weird look about his face
he's ugly i know
i didn't want to say it but i did i just
wasn't going to be the one to say but
now that you've said it that's like a
huge weight off
really really ugly like i wouldn't be
surprised if you arranged to crash the
plane just to get rid of that ugly
little [ __ ] like bob you're
ugly but this is like i thi this is
this is ugly i'm just i'm fine i'm fine
i
i'm not i don't know i'm jealous of you
guys
[ __ ] damn it did your campfire just go
flying through the air is that what i
just saw
wait wait yeah where's my campfire
i cut
[Laughter]
if a tree hit my campfire i'm going to
assume that campfire is going to go
flying so i think that's a feature
it was a by accident we need more sticks
i need to go into the
deeper woods and just get a bunch of uh
smaller trees because
i could huck down some sticks for you we
could use them yeah we could use them we
needed for log holders and like holders
of things so
a couple steeps we need what like 16
sticks for that one hold it yeah we need
tons of sticks
also if you look around the base of the
mountain sort of
to the left from camp there a tree sort
of chop like between camp and you wade
trees are sort of falling all
willy-nilly over here
what there aren't quite do what
you're what well
probably nothing yeah on this difficulty
i imagine nothing could possibly go
wrong
i don't think we've made any noise or
any impact on this environment to draw
attention either you're right
not yet i forgot this was a harder
difficulty oh my god you make
crazy ass grunting noises when you down
strike with the axe
oh yeah yeah you didn't know whoa
i'm just an accident over here bro oh
okay as long as you're just accidental
make sure
okay log holders it is ready to go i
gracefully descended the mountain so
safely home down here now look at this
littered with logs ariel look at us i
got the log holder but i realized maybe
just a pile of logs might have been a
better idea it can only hold like seven
just pile them they're not gonna like
despawn are they no i don't think so
well we got logs we were worried about
logs we got logs
do you want to sleep it off till morning
and i can go try to find a turtle for
this water collector
i'm hungry uh you don't even have any
food
i stepped in the fire oh my you are oh
yeah are you okay
with the water go to the water go to the
water the river going the river
all the all the deer are like oh lord
okay i'm fine
this man's is on fire you okay man you
sure
yeah good you were on fire like on fire
you were on fire yeah we sleeping uh
yeah let's sleep i
think i'm the middle one c oh
z z c is slave
well i vote to sleep camp out
oh what oh this morning all right i
guess i'm off on
oh my hunger went way down from that i
hunted some small game
i think we need a better better campfire
to cook so i'm going to
take to make a bow and arrow we should
probably get one of those
what is happening i'm building a better
campfire that i can actually cook oh
okay
apparently i could have cooked on the
other one i'm just dumb sounds like it
yeah i'm gonna put a bunny trap over
here yeah dude try and get us a bunny
i also put two pieces of small meat on
the fire on the
stone campfire so when that's done you
can have those it's 31 sticks for a
bunny trap
holy jeez holy geez
i'm grinding some sticks my dude me too
i'm gonna get him
hey guys i found a human skull on a
stick over here is that good is that a
good thing
yeah i think that's a good thing oh
there's a camera in there wow that's
pretty fancy actually
how do you de-equipped your lighter i
don't know i just infinitely have it in
my hand now
help ethereal demons inside my ears
help me i'm making a journey to the
beach in hopes of finding a
turtle shell i might starve to death on
the way i thought we got did we get
extra food from the plane do i don't
have anything to snack on
well i mean how many times have i said
there's how many times i've said there's
small game meat on the fire
eat some i'm not there anymore you were
there no no no no no okay all right i
guess you weren't
i finished your trap oh thank you
hopefully that's resettable
jeez if it's not 33 sticks
for one rabbit all right what else we
got here we got rabbit cage
oh can we make him breed oh mark i think
you have to take the meat off the fire
no you didn't burn you eat it right on
the fire i did
and it's burnt to [ __ ] and it's not
giving me any
any actual it's burnt to an actual
crisp okay you don't like my cooking huh
apparently not
apparently this is your freaking
strategy eight out of ten mark eight out
of ten
ah also l puts your lighter away
there's a bunny standing here mocking me
there's a some kind of a weird animal
that's just me some kind of a marmot
marmoset
the squirrel is now dead all right
i wonkalized it all right bob when that
food is ready you eat it okay
all right there's a bird in a rock i'm
gonna take care of it how do i know when
it's ready
uh you'll know you'll know do i need to
be watching it to know no no
no no no no you'll know i put some meat
on the fire and i don't know where the
hell it went
it's cooking it's cooking man there's
one bob oh yeah there we go
oh that was a good one i did a big chunk
of big chunk of noms
i know we just have to so some of the
recipes just aren't in the book you
actually have to physically just drag
stuff on your how do you know when it's
like constructable
so it'll give you like a gear it'll make
a fun noise so like i put a stick a rope
and a cloth and it gave me like a ding
and showed the
did you do it no because i think it
might be a torch but i guess i could
it's a bow
i don't have any arrows or anything but
wow
[Laughter]
guys can we put it
oh
oh my god oh oh
i'm so proud of pan of feather
[ __ ] genius good
job wow wait can i have feather back i
think i need
it somebody make other pan a feather
you want me to make pan of feather or do
you want me to just give you feather
give me feather hang on one second pan
okay let's get
pan feather um we built our house near
some heads on a stick over here yeah it
was over there it's a nice area
dude thank you for panic you you made
one too
look at you and
a feather am i right
wait wait wait you're gonna love this i
got a new new treat
pan of meat look at you
give me meat you can do anything with a
pan huh
yeah man raw small meat i'm gonna equip
that i found a bible stamp
die oh my god is that
near just standing there letting you
murder it
sure holy [ __ ] dude don't come
[Laughter]
that deer was just like oh okay
can't do anything about it i guess a
rabbit just ran into our fire and died
great mark look i got a rabbit
i'm doing it guys i'm really doing it
good job man you want a rabbit head you
want a
deer wait you know what i have a craft
idea hang on
hang on i gotta have a thought about
this
oh hang on i gotta shuffle this i gotta
shuffle some inventory around
are you telling me i can't make pan of
rabbit head
a panda head is exactly what i would
like right now oh my god
and of head yeah i knew i get why you
wanted to play this game now it's
amazing i totally see it
i have a bow how in god's name do i make
arrows it seems like
a stick plus an arrow is only one third
of the thing
wait so what if i do hatchet plus stick
that's nothing
hatchet is half of something hatchet
plus cloth
is something what did i make i made that
cloth hatchet
guys i made another craft
mark look at cloth hatchet
look what i made birdie come look at
this invention
bird look at cloth hatchet he's not
impressed
okay well the bird was really judging
about cloth hatchet
i put big uh big meat on the fire so
when that's done eat that up
there's a package from fedex on the
beach bob
what i i took your innovation and i
expanded on it
on the entire game mark you need to put
that somewhere that belongs in a museum
is that your meat are you trying to eat
that i eat one you can eat the other
yeah
go for it all right if only we had a
tortoiseshell here for the rain
i know this rain is beautiful wait light
light light what am i lighting up
[Laughter]
what exactly did i just it was not what
mark
lit his rock on fire and it lit him
on fire i don't understand
there's just a bunch of cavemen
experiment
oh it's a burning weapon all right hey
look mark i miss beer
you made a spear i made a spear
[Applause]
what did i make axe stone axe twice as
good as my regular axe
why did i just gloat glug i just got
full thirst by globe glugging while
standing here
what oh wait there's hot buttons hot
oh i think i just consumed my last soda
like two or three is like eat food or
gluggy gloves
snow i'm a genius everything is fine
where are you i found a mountain what
the hell
i'm just trying to find the beach with
turtles man i think it's closer it's
gonna be close to where you guys are
i don't think it's all the [ __ ] way
up here in bumsville
hey i killed an iguano guy nice
i did too i took his skin his body in
its head oh i got his head before i just
huck it
yeah man huck it you can actually place
heads like as trophies on your
structures nice is the blueberries good
to eat
yeah yeah yeah yeah you get coconut
water from those the the ones that are
two berries
two berries next to each other are
poisonous you do not want those
oh they're like clusters of like five
berries is that bad
try it and you'll see well i ate some of
the blue ones so i guess we'll learn
we'll learn together the blue ones are
should be good make a watercolor thank
you yes make a water collect thank you
for the [ __ ] advice
i know wait did you know we're supposed
to find a turtle to make a water
collector oh no i never considered the
fact we might need a turtle shell thank
you for letting me know
i don't know why he's such a dick about
it calm down what's wrong oh sorry
sorry i'm just a little i've been in the
[ __ ] snowy mountains and
it's not our fault you wandered off into
the [ __ ] abyss
yeah we didn't ask you to do that the
beach is
right next to us i just feel like
there's an external power watching that
is judgmental you're not blaming us but
you're being pretty rude to us if i
i'll bring you a feather pen to make up
for it i'm sorry is this gonna be a cool
wall
like i'm just gonna dude i'm on board i
like it it's good thing no one can jump
over these
wade where are you uh heading toward the
opposite coast i hope
god i'm trying to kill these birds so
one day i will find
this [ __ ] water let me know if you
find bob's kid out there too
for children you see me explode that
bird into chunks
dude it didn't stand a chance whoa oh
i mean nope oh my god
why is this deer bloody why is this deer
bloody why is this deer bloody
maybe because you're murdering it it was
pretty bloody and now it's clean
it's clean i cleaned it i figured out
how to make the arrows
nice more
but what was the recipe for arrows stick
and five feathers
gives you five arrows dude there's so
many free i just separated rocks over
here
are these rocks respawning is this i
don't know there's so many rocks in this
place
there's no place i've ever been in my
life that has this kind of population of
rocks
like knows we need rock and it's like
hell yeah
this bloody dude maybe it's 20 years
back what the hell is happening
i'm gonna build the rock wall in this
corner for fun go for it man
go for it right to the mound right to
the mound
right to the mound you don't want to
like a door on this side that was good
uh oh yeah you can have a door over
there that's why i'll do like a one i'll
do like a
door yeah i think actually you could
stack these from what i was seeing yo
yeah yeah you can so we could do a
second layer i'm gonna do this i'll just
that that'll really give you the
defenses yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah look at that oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no no
no no no no no no no no no are you gonna
parry
not even close man not even ow
who her i'm dying of thirst apparently
dying of thirst hurts like a punch of
the gut
wait have you found the turtles in the
water yet i believe i actually just
found the right
beach turtle beach i think so i see the
boat here
okay just be careful out there but now
it's dark so i can't see anything
you're literally at the beach we were at
mark look in the distance where his
character is yeah wait
we didn't see the boat no we came from
that direction if we'd had gone right
instead of left i believe we would have
found the boat if that's where the boat
is
yeah don't don't say these things to me
we would we were right there it's been
long it's your fault are you hearing the
screeching horn in the distance no i
i heard that earlier though and you guys
didn't hear it
torch well the torch doesn't throw light
very far this torch is useless
well if you have infinite lighter why
even torch bro this is why
well i didn't know i would have stuck
with the lighter it's exact same amount
of light distance
this has this is the beach this is
turtle beach i know it is
you okay yeah i think he's doing so good
he's not doing so good
dude the lighter gives off more light
than the torch my lighter went out and i
couldn't see
wall holding the torch i don't think we
should let him back in the camp
i'm on board with that i'm on board with
that i think he should probably build
his own he's probably there's turtles
here
get them i know they're here i i smell
them
these rocks are dead ass respawning
though
okay calm down mark and i have only
constructed an
entire fortress in the time it's taken
you to get
one turtle shell not trying to make you
feel bad just
just spitting hot fire over here i feel
bad
can i equip more than one turtle shell
can i carry more than what i mean oh my
god
if you come back with one turtle shell
oh there's a bunny in our trap
that's a squirrel hell yes dude
i blame you for this do you have to kill
it to get it out
i don't know i killed on the floor can i
is there a dragger
can i can i build something like a can i
build a what's
there like a log sled or something yeah
but that's all slugs okay i like that
what was that under oh is that only for
logs it's not like a sled of logs it's a
sled four logs
i think it's a sled four logs oh never
mind that won't help you at all wayne
you're welcome look at our freaking
fortress yeah dude
dude it's coming from the other first
serious though i don't know what
magic is causing rocks to be birthed
from the earth but thank god
yeah i think this can you imagine if we
had to just find this many rocks oh my
god
what if i built that what if i built a
raft and i floated back to u-haul
that's the wrong game bro there is no
there's rafts there's boats and we got a
rock
game bro we played that one very
different
i'm dying of starvation i should
probably build like a small fire and eat
real quick
come put the turtle thing in come on
you're not that far from us i
have food on the fire for you i was
wondering if we could build
like an arch over this basically is that
possible
like you see what i'm saying oh yeah
wait actually
that's that's like maybe possible let's
build up those sides and see i guess
oh we could we'll we could build a wall
with door in our doorways
oh do you guys know what direction i am
from camp so if i need to come back this
way you know which way i should run
you're over there like look mark look
what i did look thank you
oh that's actually pretty sick right
that works
that works right that's kind of sick
yeah that's sick all right i'm doing
that i'm doing that everywhere
all right sounds good oh my god it does
mark
you are a master craftsman can i just
say that
look at how that fits oh that's perfect
you are
absolutely that's perfect a master of
your craft
oh my god unappreciated in your time
and i cannot this one here
it cannot overstate the extent to which
you are a goddamn
genius thank you thank you you guys want
to save a little bit of that praise for
me
i mean no i'm talking mark's dick right
now hang on seriously though that fills
a spot in my soul i
didn't even know it was there in a way
that's scary it's almost deeply
satisfying
how you doing wade good are you uh
contributing you contributing i got that
i don't think he's contributing as much
as
mark is contributing can i say that what
about you bob
how much i'm just supporting you you are
the genius mastermind behind all of this
victory that's happening
doorway to my rock wall you can't go
through wow
wow we really are team meant to be yeah
simpatico we synergize
like hall of notes
like those dutch oats everyone's raving
about oh yeah whatever the hell that is
yeah
yeah all right no we're at the camp
still
i'm being followed by a naked person
well don't bring them back to camp
that's a compliment no dude
dude
i did the old run down the hill fast
trick they couldn't keep up
oh he's trying to encroach on your
genius territory mark
you guys no just you
what i've got a turtle shell hey friends
are you back
i'm back there's a hell of a
accomplishment you guys have here
yep if anyone wants meat i accidentally
cooked way more than i need
good job wow you did one thing
look at all the rest of what we've done
and compare it to what you know
gladly stayed here and built a wall if
you guys want to get the next couple
turtle shells we didn't ask you to go
i will happily quickly and efficiently
get as many turtle shells as you request
my good
now that you know where they're at i
would hope so yeah that's the that's the
thing that was holding you back yeah
so did a supper's ready fellers all
right din din
my hungry boys come get your little way
i ate over at jimmy's house i'm not
hungry
all right well i'll eat yours that's
fine nobody appreciates me in this
family that's fine
i appreciate you this is delicious food
thank you genius mastermind thank you
rock of my soul rock of your loins call
me rock if you're loins dude
that's all i've ever wanted all right
three rocks left until
castle of an abode is completed
at this then cool
now can we expand and put in a log cabin
no no
not right now we need about six more
turtle shells that's what we need
yeah can you get six more i was freezing
to death and i think i still am
if i was what does it say if you're
freezing to death i have
ice all over my screen oh well that'll
do it
oh we can build a s a so sign
so people know we're saucers all right
it's morning time to go back and get
some more turtle shells
oh well that's i think they're on fire
the man who can't avoid lighting himself
on fire
should let the real hero here go get the
uh
by all means what if we made an
adventure out let's go all three ghosts
we can get three turtle shells and we
can explore the boat while we're there
and get all the goodies on the boat
ah he makes a good point bob that is a
good point
all right well you can catch up to me
nerds okay all right
oh he's already he's already left us
mark he's already on the way
why are you talking no no marcus my bro
you can't be frozen with mark mark's my
bro i'm i'm kind of blessed we're no
we're not bros and we're brosons
no no come on susan's at best yeah
oh come on not no we're susan's man hang
on brosnan i'm on the way
come on no uh if you were wondering wait
i was not talking to you
i was talking to bob my brother i know
you were but you could have been talking
i got the the turtle shell i found the
bee you did it you did one you did one
good thing you did it
i helped finish the wall i found out the
spot we built our base on
sure dude berries that are maybe
poisonous maybe not we'll
find out later good berries give me the
juices oh yeah
i have i take a umbrance i take umbrage
with the the chewing noises in this game
this person like
doesn't have cheeks when they eat food
that sound just
shoots out of their teeth it resonates
like it's amplified
oh mushy's probably bad mushies no oh
yeah that's what that is
so here's the house that's by the beach
where we totally were and could have
built our structure earlier
with the sleeping nooses you remember
different place man that's
no no no that's the place with the
sleeping there's many more
houses oh do they have do they have more
sleeping nooses i can steal would they
have go away
maybe not are you sure oh
they might have some good goodies good
goodies circuit boards and stuff guys
you think anyone's gonna care if i just
take these i think you should in all
honesty
good yeah go for it oh there's a sony
pop on the ground
there's also a person
oh god hello people
uh guys uh guys uh guys uh guys
[Music]
you